I'm really proud of you for going on
this trip you're gonna have so much fun
similar to the first film somewhere to
Jurassic Park that was a movie that was
designed to be seen in the theater
because there's so much spectacle
involved we try to design an experience
that was going to be conducive to large
format I love big scope and I love big
movies but I also want those movies to
have an intimacy and a sense of humanity
to that bringing that feeling to this
was my absolute number one priority
you know the IMAX experience
specifically in this it's a pretty
stunning experience you really do feel
the difference I think this is the kind
of movie that needs to be seen in a
theater you'll be able to watch this on
two-dimensional you know media through
the course of your life forever on and
downloaded or watching on TV or DVD or
blu-ray or something but seeing this in
the theater on a sixty foot wide screen
in IMAX and feeling the dinosaurs in
your lap I think it's the beauty of a
movie like this you just can't feel the
largest of it when you're watching it
say on your phone or even on your TV you
just don't feel it but when you're
sitting in the theater watching it in
IMAX I mean the sound makes you
physically vibrate watching the movie is
like going on some kind of theme park
ride
because we wanted so many moments to
feel like a nature film you know the
Mosasaurus all these you know Jacques
Cousteau kind of moments and I think the
IMAX experience specifically in this you
know in addition to 3d it's the way to
go I think people can expect a blast
when they see this in theaters and
particularly in iMac I think people
don't lose their minds